well you have fun with your uh with your
friend friends
yikes okay bye
sweet conversations hey what is going on
YouTube so now I know I said when I
started doing these videos
now I'm gonna say I'm gonna throw that
guru what I said I was gonna do these
videos and I wasn't gonna stress out too
much about these topics I literally
meant that there's a lot of things that
go on in this [ __ ] crazy head of mind
but I really do want to express and talk
about and I feel like most of you have
been saying just just go ahead just say
what's on your mind so imma do it I'm
gonna be free that's a little bird big
bird
a really [ __ ] big bird you know
recently I had a conversation with
somebody who's a lot younger than I am
and they got into a relationship and
they said something to me that was by
far one of the funniest [ __ ] things
I've ever heard of my life now what you
hear there's this might remind you of
yourself when you're like eighteen
sixteen or maybe even like 14 years old
so what this person said was this is the
first time I feel like I really vibe
with somebody and to be honest with you
I don't even think that will fight ever
I don't even know what will fight about
it [ __ ] because isn't that what
everybody says when they first get
together with somebody the first things
you say when you're in your first like
real serious relationship or by far some
of the dumbest [ __ ] things you can
ever say when you're in your very first
serious relationship of course you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're gonna fight
about you idiot because all you see is
like hard beans all you see is love
birds [ __ ] each other an elk
goes across a creek drinks the water
while the bigger elf [ __ ] it in the ass
we call that the infatuation stage which
everybody goes to remember that [ __ ]
remember when you first fell in love and
you saw that person and they said yes
you were like oh my god not to say that
the person that you're with right now
you're not gonna stay with them but what
I'm saying is that when you stay with
people you also start to find things
that you hate about them too
one of the first things that I find out
that took me by surprise is that the
qualities that
really really love about somebody turns
out to be the quality that you [ __ ]
hate about them like for example I love
women who are strong have a really good
opinion and they can hold their own in a
conversation independent I love that
[ __ ] dude I'd like to want to grow hold
your [ __ ] [ __ ] now and it's great
when they hold their own in an argument
with somebody that's not kill it's like
with me and my girlfriend I'm like oh my
god she's awesome she's beautiful she's
so strong headed I love it but watching
the argument when she's completely wrong
and she's strong at it but no goddamn
reason yeah you thought you loved that
[ __ ] huh you ever try arguing with
somebody that doesn't listen the reason
I'm gonna tell you this funny [ __ ]
story and the only reason why I have
proof that I was right in this case is
because there were when defense like a
[ __ ] murder scene that's the
only way you could win an argument with
your girlfriend is if you have witnesses
you see that you know sorry
Gracie so Muriel and I one day went to
go get some bunny sandwiches right if
you don't know what bunnies aren't
they're Vietnamese sandwiches they're
[ __ ] delicious and they're one of my
favorite things to eat so I wanted to
take her to a place that I loved and
Along Came my roommate Khalif and also
my brother John sounds like I'm talking
about my apostles brother John bring me
my scriptures so I stopped going to get
these buggy sandwiches she looks at the
menu and clearly it's all of it nummies
as she goes so which way should I get to
eat and of course being the helpful
boyfriend that I am I decided to say
number one in number six is my favors so
I suggest that you probably stick with
those cuz I haven't gotten anything else
here and after I said that she goes to
the register and says yeah number four
please and I'm just sitting there like
okay [ __ ] why the [ __ ] you ask then
okay that's cool so after that we go
outside there's no seating in there so
we sit outside on the curb move we start
to eat our sandwiches and I'm going to
town on my sandwich that [ __ ] was
delicious as [ __ ] but I'll enjoy my
sandwich I look over to my right and I
see my girlfriend look at her sandwich
like you don't want a girl dislikes
something they gotta make a big-ass
[ __ ] scene about it I saw her [ __ ]
face nobody eat a [ __ ] sandwich like
that so I'm looking at it I kind of
inquired like do you not like your
sandwich what's going on no I don't like
that much how many at once again this
sucks
[Music]
number one number six is my favorite so
I suggest that you probably stick with
those cuz I haven't gotten anything else
here the cash register
can I get a number four please P a
four-second you know what's interesting
like girls can always make you feel like
you're gonna go insane like you're crazy
like your memory just disappeared like
what I know I told her this was that
we're kind of getting into like this
lightweight argument about y'all I was
trying to help you out
and she's looking at me like I'm placed
like yo who brought me to the sandwich
place why don't you tell me which that
was to get Bellomo hole why I always
tell you fellas to always have witnesses
is because cuddly and my brother John
were there and they said nah he told you
and all of a sudden she looks at them
starts laughing it's so funny like when
you're in a relationship like you could
tell your boyfriend and girlfriend
they're saving their friends dead but
because it comes from you suddenly
you're insulting them do you like this
t-shirt it's cool I like the other shirt
you were wearing actually but it is her
friends you like this shirt not have to
go like yo one oh you're bragging right
oh listen here trust me when I got
together with the woman that I love
right now I never would have thought
that she would have turned into a
monster
I'm kidding I'm not perfect either I'm
only remembering like fun [ __ ] that we
went through in the past but now people
then but when you're a fat she waited
and you're in the beginning stages of
love you can only see positive things
you don't see the problems because
that's not the moment that you're in
right now but what I think when you tell
yourself that you're never gonna fight
with that person when you do get into a
fight it leaves you to be a little bit
disappointed so I don't like setting
like false expectation when it comes to
relationships I kind of like to look at
it like this no matter what no matter
who you're with you're always gonna get
into a [ __ ] fight with them it
doesn't matter I feel like guys and
girls are so [ __ ] different and
people in general are so different
there's absolutely no way that you're
gonna see eye to eye with everything in
the whole span of your [ __ ]
relationship you want to disagree you
are going to fight because that's just
how it is especially when you get
married and you're in front of that
[ __ ] person's face every day for the
rest of your goddamn life but in my
relationship I'm happy
I'm kidding I'm absolutely kidding we
love each other we still get into fights
every now and then but it's pretty
[ __ ] good and a lot of these stories
that I'm telling you our stuff from like
years ago I went from blind love to
faithful love meaning that the more I
got to know this person even though
there were qualities that I didn't
really maybe like about her or stuff
that we kind of butt heads on I actually
learned to love her more to endure
everything with her and that's the type
of relationship that I love and to sum
it up I think that's what it is to be in
a serious relationship nothing's perfect
and it's not supposed to be your
relationship is never supposed to be
exactly how it is when it first starts
supposed to evolve and if you look back
at your relationship but you say that
first time that you guys were together
was better than what you have now then
you might have a problem Muriel you are
the stain to my tighty-whities I know
you don't like it when I compliment you
like that
but the growing pains are pretty funky
because even though I was talking to
this person about them saying it
I remember when Muriel actually looked
at me and said that too she goes I
really don't see what we're gonna fight
about and I kind of looked at her like
me neither